the indianapolis colts are not a jv team
they are playing a
kind of jv team but once they get some
help around joe burrow they won't be
the cults have closed their facility
they've issued the statement this is the
latest hold your breath and wait and see
what happens moment they've got several
individuals who have tested positive for
covert 19 the team is currently in the
process of confirming those tests now
this happened yesterday with the falcons
they shut it all down because of one
positive test there were some reports
that it was four it was just one and
they determined it was a false positive
peter i don't get it
how in the hell are these nfl teams all
having false positives and it seems like
every time over the past week other than
tennessee in new england it's been a
positive it has been a false positive it
happened with the jets last friday it
happened with the falcons yesterday and
it's almost like presumed like we're
just temporarily shutting down while we
wait for the news that it really was a
false positive well what if it's not and
you've got several
for several
several for all of them to be false
positives to me that's a bigger problem
than having positives because you can't
trust your testing accuracy if that many
come back positive at any given moment
mike i think one of the important things
and this is a probably a 180 from the
question that you asked but you know
that's why i'm used to watching
so
when the new york jets when the new york
jets had their problem
okay you know what helped them what
helped them is that their bio reference
testing lab was 24 miles away in elmwood
park new jersey
and the reason that that helped him is
that instead of let's say you're the new
orleans saints and you have to put your
test uh you have to put your kovid test
on an airplane i think to houston
and you know if you're the seattle
seahawks and you have to put your tests
on an airplane to california you can't
get them back uh you know maybe as
quickly as a team like the jets or the
giants or the uh the houston texans
by the time
those teams say well look these might be
false positives and we have to go get
them
checked i mean it's very easy by that
time and if you have to give additional
testing it's very easy for them to do
that to get the results back faster than
most teams quite frankly in the nfl so
and i doubt i don't think that uh that
the colts have a facility in
indianapolis i don't know about the
atlanta falcons but
those are the kind of things right now
that allow teams to work a little bit
faster in getting over and getting the
knowledge about these negative tests
yeah and isn't that just a strange
dynamic to all of this that how close
you are to the lab
allows you to find out sooner than other
teams whether or not it is a false
positive whether or not you're all clear
whatever the case may be and that's one
thing that i was hearing a couple of
weeks ago because
one team was getting their results like
at four in the morning the titans get
them at four in the morning others were
getting them that night others are
getting the next morning and i had
different people saying oh wait a minute
you're wrong when you said that that
team gets it at eight o'clock we get it
it whenever and it's like no you know
when i started asking around it's like
no everybody gets them at different
times it's all driven by right how close
the lab is to the team
something about that that seems odd to
me and this goes back to may i remember
after the draft when the nfl kind of did
a victory lap of sorts about getting the
draft done
and then you pivot to okay we got a
season coming in a few months are we
going to be ready for it
the impression that the nfl had the
people in positions of power had at the
time was the testing would be so much
more advanced and you'd be able to do
what they call a point-of-care test
where you don't have to send it off to a
laboratory and you have close to 100
percent certainty that it's a positive
that's real it's a negative that's real
and you can do it before you even walk
in the facility and the fact that the
technology hasn't gotten to that point
really is a problem for some of these
teams they have to wait a differing
amount of hours to find out is it a
false positive is it a true positive is
it well you're not going to find out if
it's a false negative until the next day
when you get the positive but
the fact that you can't get the
information right away
is going to hurt some of these teams
it's going to complicate situations like
what the colts are dealing with this
morning
mike you know what else i see happening
here you know as we discuss this so look
at the two games right now that you
would think
are in some jeopardy this weekend okay
one is indianapolis and cincinnati the
other is atlanta and minnesota
we may now be getting to the point
where the nfl
if they don't play these games this
weekend where the nfl sort of holds in
abeyance the decision about what they're
going to do
and maybe they wait and tentatively say
yes uh we will have a decision
at some point in the future about
whether we are going to play these games
and when we are going to play these
games because it's like i've been told
all along mike that if the atlanta
falcons uh enter let's say week uh the
you know game 16 if they enter game 16
with a you know three and 12 record and
the minnesota vikings are you know five
and ten let's just say
um then there's a good chance they're
not going to make that game up unless
they abs unless they create a week 18
but i i don't think the nfl is going to
be motivated
to absolutely have to play 16 game
season for everybody if the games do not
matter
uh toward the playoffs now you would
think that the bengals game against the
colts could matter to the to the colts
and they absolutely want to play that
game but we don't really know that right
now which is why i will not be surprised
i don't know what they're going to do i
will not be surprised if the nfl says i
will tell you down the road uh about the
status of this game
yeah peter my understanding is that when
something like this arises and there's a
complication with one of these games
howard katz the scheduling guru for the
nfl has a program available to him where
he can punch in the game that needs to
be postponed and instantly gets all of
the options for making it work but
that's all premised on the various teams
affected having flexibility and the main
flexibility in the schedule comes from
the bye week as the bye weeks begin to
go away
the chances of fixing these
postponements by saying we're gonna move
this game here we're gonna move this
game here look they had seven moves they
had to make to accommodate a one-week
delay of broncos patriots you're going
to run out of options at some point and
that's when week 18 comes into play and
i'll just say this as it relates to the
possibility of a 5-10
vikings team playing a two and thirteen
falcons team
that game may mean a hell of a lot when
it comes to the chase for trevor
lawrence
so
you know
while we may avoid having winning
percentage determine who gets in the
playoffs
maybe winning percentage deter or losing
percentage determines who gets trevor
lawrence
and in a roundabout way that's another
reason to try to play a game that
otherwise doesn't matter for playoff
purposes even if you're not going for
the first but i just don't see him like
a clear picture of of who deserves which
pick in the top ten
i get it but i don't think that's a
reason to add another week to the
schedule i just don't and i don't think
the nfl is going to do that i think they
would rather have the draft order
basically made up by a winning
percentage and and look
you know all we're doing right now is
speculating i'm telling you what i
believe to be true
because the other thing about howard
cats and yes they do do modeling based
on okay how many moves do we have to
make to get this game in week 10 let's
just say all right but mike
do you want to use
all those moves
on a game between an o and five team and
a one in four team do you i don't
i you know there's only a finite number
and there's going to be another team
next week or the week after there's only
a finite number of moves you can make
you're much better off rescheduling the
game between four and one and three and
two teams because as of right now though
that game
uh has a much better chance of of having
a bearing on the playoff race
and before we take a break remember this
the chris mad dog russo suggestion from
last week which is brilliant and i think
this is what the league will do if there
is an 18th week you don't tack it on to
the end of the schedule you make week 18
week 17 week 17 that crescendo of games
that determines everything for the most
part playoff positioning who's in who's
out that becomes your week 18. so the
makeup games would be right before that
if they do have to do it and it feels
like it feels like it's moving in that
direction and every day that we get one
of these clarence beaks crop reports
with positive tests from this city or
this city or that city especially on a
thursday or friday it really increases
the chances that it's going to happen in
a week where they can't make the game up
and we are going to have an 18th week
somewhere
somehow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports